in a previous video we used a
particulate model like this to
understand a reaction not just
understand the reaction but to balance
but to balance the chemical reaction as
well and when i hand drew these
particles the atoms in this particulate
model here i tried to draw it pretty
close to their actual relative sizes
carbon atoms are a little bit bigger
than oxygen atoms and they're both a lot
bigger than hydrogen atoms what we're
going to do in this video is extend our
understanding using a particulate model
to start to visualize what actually
might go on in a mixture of some of
these reactant molecules
so what i have here on the left hand
side are the various molecules i have
two methane molecules here i have three
water molecules and what i want to do
with you
is draw what we would expect to see
after the reaction and i encourage you
like always pause this video and see if
you can have a go at that maybe with a
pencil and paper at least just try to
imagine it in your head before i do this
with you
all right now let's do this together
now we know that for every methane and
every water we're going to produce
one carbon monoxide and three molecular
hydrogens and each of those molecules of
hydrogen have two hydrogens in them so
let's just say
that this one and this one react they're
going to produce one carbon monoxide i'm
going to try to draw the relative sizes
roughly right so one
carbon
monoxide and then they're going to
produce six
hydrogen atoms that are going to be in
three hydrogen molecules
so let's do
that's two
and
four
and then i'll just do one here and then
six
all right so i took care of this one and
this one and now we can imagine that
maybe
this water molecule reacts with this
methane molecule and so that would
produce another carbon monoxide let me
draw that roughly at the right size
another
carbon
monoxide
molecule
and three more hydrogen molecules or for
a total of six more hydrogens so that's
one
and two
[Music]
and
three
and now we have this water right over
here that had no one to react with in
this situation had no partner and so
that's just going to be a leftover
reactant molecule so
let me just draw it right over here so
that water
could be
right
over
right over here and so this was a useful
way of starting to visualize what might
be going on remember this is happening
at a very high temperature they're all
bouncing around etc and then when they
react you might get this but then this
water molecule has no one to react to so
it is you could view it as a leftover
after the reaction